good morning everybody um I may be the
only one that got the memo but we did
have subcommittee today for our bail
hearings correct for our bail
working
charge this to I am not I will do my
chairmanship I am going
to ask for forgiveness and step away
show
okay at this time I'm going to open the
criminal justice subcommittee work
session on House Bill
470 relative to fental test strips and
Other Drug checking equipment if you
could please rise and join me with the
Pledge of
aliance
okay thank you we're going to take a a
representative
okay I will be reopening the criminal
justice subcommittee work session on on
House Bill uh
470 uh I'll have representative Muse
when he's available to come and speak
Amendment thank you very
much um I have a draft Amendment uh that
uh I'm proposing today uh members of the
committee also have a marked up version
uh of the original bill that actually
shows where the uh the specific changes
are but to give you a a highlevel
overview um one of the things that I
tried to do in putting this together was
really not only listen uh to folks who
are are basically trying to expand drug
checking and trying to do the best they
can to to save lives but um I I also
tried to listen to some of the the very
very legitimate concerns of law
enforcement and one of those concerns
was around um striking the words testing
uh and analyzing uh from the drug drug
paraphernalia law altoe the concern that
was raised was that uh people who
manufacture and compound uh illegal
drugs uh use this equipment and uh one
of the concerns that they rais is for
folks like that uh possession of this
equipment for compounding and
Manufacturing purposes should continue
to be a crime so one of the another way
to come at this is to create a clearer
exemption uh for drug checking uh
equipment uh and processes which which
I've tried to done to do um so in the
amendment one of the things that we have
in there that's not in the original bill
is the language for HB 287 which we
passed earlier this year which legalizes
fentanyl test strips and xylazine test
strips so uh at the time we actually put
this particular bill in uh HP 470 uh
neither one of the two bills had been
passed but we're not in that situation
anymore
um so uh so the text for 270 is in there
um I think it's also important to
realize that um that the bill does uh
some other important things uh so for
instance one of the issues that you can
potentially have uh with drug checking
is that while we've made we've made it
um uh essentially we've we've uh
decriminalized the use of uh fentel and
xylazine test drips by uh people who are
actually using the drugs what we haven't
really done is
decriminalized um supplying those uh and
and and having used test strips uh in
the possession of people you know who
are actually helping people with you
know with the test strips and with with
the drug checking so one of the things
that we wanted to try to do uh in this
particular Amendment and in this
particular Bill uh is to address that
the other thing that we are trying to do
is to really acknowledge that when it
comes to contaminant and adulterant in
the drug Supply um it's a continually
moving Target and
currently the approach that we've take
or the approach the approach that we
took with with HB 287 were was to create
two specific exceptions for uh fentanyl
test strips and pryazine uh test strips
to the uh to the drug paraphernalia law
um meanwhile we've heard that there are
other contaminants such as lolle uh
benzodiazapine uh that are actually in
the drug Supply and are being found in
the drug Supply
um uh
benzodiazapine uh is uh more familiar I
think to a lot of people same class of
drugs as uh
Valium uh and lorazapam
and uh what they do is they produce a
more they they produce a uh kind of an
accentuated or accelerated kind of a
high the danger is is in combination
with
cocaine um in combination with opioids
and some of the other things that they
uh can be cut with they can have an
unpredictable result uh probably not as
devastating as as fentanyl uh but still
potentially very damaging for the folks
who use
them uh um
liso uh is actually a uh a drug that is
an anti-parasitic drug that uh looks an
awful lot uh like uh Like Cocaine uh
from what I understand so it's used as a
cutting agent
um this is again uh another drug that uh
that can produce um uh effects similar
to xylazine with open wounds and things
of that nature uh and uh I believe it it
also can produce uh clef pellet uh in
children uh you know uh so we we're
we're talking about things that um are
starting to enter the drug the drug
Supply now that we really don't have a
way of accounting for and and I think
one of the things that we wanted to try
to do with with this bill and the
changes to this bill is to create more
flexibility um that would allow uh that
would allow these drugs to be tested
before they're used um and and I think
the idea is you know to save as many
lives as we can uh and I think the other
part of it is one of the things that
we're seeing as especially with things
like xylazine and LOL is that some of
these the negative impacts for people um
the wounds that they create um the
difficulty of treating some of these
wounds um uh create uh a burden on the
system uh that that has to treat F the
folks that have to treat them um and can
create long lasting damaging impacts in
in people who never really had any idea
uh that they were taking these drugs in
the first
place um kind of going
over some of the other things that the
amendment uh that the amendment
does
see one of the one of the things that
has come up in some of our uh some of
our discussions is the definition of a
nominal amount and I wanted to I wanted
to speak to that um uh in other states
uh 10 mg uh when a nominal amount is
defined uh does tend to be the amount uh
that's chosen and there are a couple of
reasons for that um one is if you look
in the the Center for Disease controls
material on you know on drug checking um
uh 10 milligrams is the recommended
amount for checking and uh there's there
was there's actually a brochure by the
New York City Health Department that I
ran into
uh that'll give you an idea just how
small uh an amount 10 milligrams
actually is it's actually an an amount
of drugs that when crushed would
basically cover Lincoln's hair on a
penny um and while some test strips are
are capable of uh providing a result um
with only a few grains one of the issues
that you run into as a practical matter
um is
uh you know how do you handle uh you
know how do you handle a drug uh that
you're trying to have checked um uh you
know when you're talking about that
smaller quantity so 10
milligrams
um just so just so we're all uh sure
this is a little spoon uh uh that Miss
McGinley handed out uh when she
testified uh here uh uh last week and
you know it it actually shows uh how
small a quantity that is imagine you
know trying to get that amount of
quantity that quantity into a plastic
bag into a small bottle into to a
position where you can test it
so even at 10 milligrams we're not
talking about something that's going to
be really easy for people to do um but
we're talking about something that's
possible for people to do if we decrease
the amount to less than 10 Mig you know
we're potentially talking about putting
a few grains in a plastic bag and then
when you open the plastic bag you know
you're going where are the grains
because we're literally talking you know
very very small grains so as a as a
practical matter one of the reasons why
uh 10 milligrams is in there and specifi
it as we thought it was important to
specify a quantity number one but we
also wanted to
be I think to to try and be as clear as
possible uh you know around um what the
see another thing that is in here let me
see let me just see if I can find
this
yeah so so I think the really the the
big thing to and and I think the big
take takeaway from this amendment are
the objections that law enforcement had
around removing testing and analyzing um
have been acknowledged in this amendment
that language is actually back in there
and what we've tried to do and I think
what we've done is we've more clearly
separated um
uh the difference between in the in the
context between using this equipment for
compounding and Manufacturing versus
using it for drug checking and and if
you look at our drug paraphernalia laws
in general I think one of the things
that you you find is that the context of
uh paraphernalia is very important and
what we're we're basically saying with
this bill is that drug checking does
provide um a different a different
context so so for examp for example
weighing and measuring equipment testing
and analyzing equipment um the equipment
itself is perfectly illegal what makes
it illegal is when you use when you use
it to manufacture compound uh or
distribute a controlled substance that's
what makes it
illegal um so I think that by more
clearly
delineating um the exception for drug
checking um and leaving the existing
language in otherwise
intact uh should address a lot of the
heard represent
new yeah I just have a quick question
about drug checking you've used that
term a couple of times and it seems to
me that it it's still blurry in my mind
as to drug checking that the individual
would do compared to the the J drug
checking that a manufacturer would do
are both of those referred to as drug
checking in the
laws drug checking actually refers to um
uh basically an enduser somebody who's
prepared to inest ingest the drugs
having the ability to use a test strip
or some other testing process uh in
order to identify a potential
contaminant so for instance if you think
you're buying oxy codone pills um uh but
you're not quite sure because you've
heard you know that it's pretty common
for fentanyl pills to be sold instead or
for Oxycodone to be combined with
fentanyl one of the things you can do is
you can use a fentanyl test strip to
detect the presence of Fentanyl and you
or you can use a a xylazine test strip
to to detect uh the presence of
xylazine um getting things like test
strips and Drug tricking equipment into
the hands of people who who are using
drugs is really where Public Health
people and uh people in the harm
reduction Community like Miss McGinley
have have come in there there is federal
money available to do that and and so
part of one of the one of the things
that the bill also does is make sure
that they're not prosecuted because
they're not actually using the uh the
drug checking equipment what they're
doing is basically Distributing it to
people who can use it uh and that's
that's kind of where we are I hope that
question it kind of does I'm just
talking about I'm talking more about
words than than situations I mean drug
checking is it refers to the individual
like you said now it also refers to the
people that provide this the equipment
the strips and stuff like that to do it
and then is there another drug checking
that is done by big manufacturers or
legally is that well that's testing and
analyzing okay so and that can be done
legally by a pharmaceutical company or
illegally by somebody with a basement
lab okay thank you uh Representatives uh
representative Muse if we could take a
look directly at your Amendment and
we'll uh
that's
2422 and for the committee if we could
just start to focus on the bolded words
and uh it's the
amendment 2023
2422 not not there yet so where the we
see the bolded words uh and that should
be page
two uh line 12 drug
paraphernalia and it just looks like
that replaces the word
it I see no issues with that does anyone
issues and then we will move down to
line 21 where testing equipment used or
intended for use Etc has been struck and
it is now testing equipment used or
intended for use in the manufacturing
compound and converting processing or
preparing of Controlled Substances for
illegal sales and or distribution in
order to identify or analyze the
strength Effectiveness or purity of a
controlled
or no okay we'll move
on yeah go ahead this is can be an open
this out of the amendment or is that so
it in representative Muse can speak
about this where it is struck out will
be removed from the actual statute and
and this will be added and this is in
terms of actual like a penalty for uh
this is the illegal of the this is yes
this this this would be the illegal
clarification this
clarify it's a clarification that really
is um is uh being more specific about
when the use of this testing equipment
is illegal um and what it and by by
wording in it in this way it actually um
opens the door to the exception for drug
checking which we've already done with
HB
repr I just want to be super clear
because I and and correct me if I'm
wrong uh representative news but so when
when we're talking about is this where
it makes it not where it makes it legal
is this where it legalizes this is the
definitions right so this is clarifying
the definition not necessarily in this
section right here in this line it's not
saying this is where it's this it's
legalized this is uh clarifying the
definition so that later when we talk
about what is legal and what is not it
parses it more clearly am I saying that
correct okay you said it much better
did thank
you now we will move on to page
three uh line
18 notwithstanding provisions of RSA 318
B1 XA or unless possessed in conjunction
with other evidence forming the basis of
a criminal charge involving
manufacturing possessing with intent to
sell or compounding pursuant to RSA 318
include
so if if you look at uh at a um when we
passed HB 287 and the governor signed it
uh and legalized fentanyl stress test
strips and xylazine test strips um we
had a change in the statute that wasn't
accounted for originally so what you
have in a is the uh is the exact change
that we made the reason why the second
part of it is actually crossed out uh is
to avoid having to repeat repeat that um
three more times in b c and d so that
exemption would apply to uh uh so unless
possessed in conjunction with other
evidence forming the basis of a criminal
charge involving the manufacturing
possession and intent to sell or
compounding pursuant uh so this is
language that we was actually
incorporated into 287 in the Senate um
that we will incor incorporate into the
statute but rather than doing it four
times in ABC and D we just do it up at
top with XB so basically the way it
reads is notwithstanding the provisions
of RSA 318 B1 XA or unless possessed in
conjunction with other evidence forming
the basis of a criminal charge involving
the manufacturing possessing with intent
to sell or compounding uh person went to
RSA 318 B2 uh one drug paraphernalia
shall not include include so this is the
section that basically uh exempts U
uh exempts drug checking equipment from
uh the paraphernalia statute and
provides that clearer dividing line uh
for uh for drug checking that um that in
a way that doesn't impact the ability of
law enforcement to uh apply the drug
paraphernalia law on somebody who is is
using testing and analyzing equipment to
drugs uh representative Muse was that
language you said was taken right from
the Senate's bill or is this yeah this
what happened we uh the senate had some
changes to HB 287 uh there was an
amendment uh after we passed it and sent
it over to the Senate uh the final
version includes this language I I
actually I wanted the hand out is
actually the the final language of HB
287 HB 287 which really inserts one
RSA okay thank you I just I have an
issue with that Senate's bill because it
says possessing with intent to sell it
says nothing about possession and I know
that that kind of gets clarified but I
guess that's not for us to really kind
of debate on the bill that was already
passed uh anything on that at all or
should I move on to the next one next
one
okay uh we'll drop down to B Other Drug
checking equipment used to inform
individuals of whether a substance has
been adulterated by the presence of a
synthetic opioid or another controlled
substance or un undisclosed chemical
compound or
contaminant so what this does would it
gives us the ability to uh and you know
and would give uh Public Health organ
organizations and harm reduction
organizations that are doing this work
the ability to introduce new drug
sharing equipment uh for different
compounds and adulterants um without
necessarily having to come back to us to
amend the statute so we've amended the
statute um uh to uh exclude uh xylazine
test strips and Fentanyl test strips uh
from our drug paraphernalia law what
what this would do is it would open the
door for for example there are
contaminants like l
and uh
benzodiazapine uh that are now uh
entering the drug Supply what what it
would do is it would make it legal uh
for uh drug checking equipment that test
for those compounds uh to be used as
well so the advantage of having language
like this is that every time there's a
new scientific advance that makes it
easier to detect something um that
somebody should know is in the drugs
that they're taking a contaminant an
adulterant or different
uh controlled substance that would give
us the flexibility to be able to do this
without having to come back and change
the statute every
time
repr just to add to that and piggy back
on it and I know we're not at this
section yet but I think that it's really
important to remember when we're talking
about including this in it that there is
actually a definition of drug checking
equipment that that goes through it so
it's not just like a wide openen um it
yeah it is it is still specified as well
you know what I mean thank you I know
we'll get to that when we get to it but
I think that is important one more as
always with laws you get a look from one
law to find what the meaning is and it's
it's very convoluted if you're not into
the law uh we'll move down to C
materials used by staff and volunteers
of agencies and organizations that
provide harm reduction Services
authorized by the state a county a
municipality or a public health
department in the processing preparing
packaging repackaging storing or
containing of a nominal amount of a
controlled substance for the purpose of
confirmatory
testing and and I think the what the
intent of this is is to make sure that
um folks like Miss McGinley uh who are
working in the harm reduction community
and who are actually working you know
with folks who are using drugs um you
know con conceivably under our law now
it's it's possible for them to be
prosecuted if they have things like used
fentanyl test strips uh and things like
that so we just want to make sure that
um that there is uh some kind of an
exemption uh for people who are trying
to get the service out there in the
community um uh again all the other
things apply um but this is basically
just sort of closing the loop and I
think what we're really trying to do
with this bill in a lot of ways is just
sort of to to close sort of some of the
loops we created when we passed 287 you
know it just it basically just goes that
tight thank
you D drug checking equipment use
purchase transported or distributed by
staff and volunteers of agencies and
organizations that Pro provide harm
reduction Services authorized by the
state a county a municipality or a
public health
department same sort of thing you know
currently um with the exception of
xylazine strips and Fentanyl test strips
drug checking equipment is considered
drug
paraphernalia um and this exemption
really applies specifically to staffs
and volunteers of agencies um that are
dealing uh with harm uh you know in you
know with harm reduction programs uh and
and who basically are really responsible
uh for getting the stuff into the
community and making sure that you know
ideally as as many people as possible
you know given the current environment
where uh there's so much contamination
um and uh and where fentanyl is such a
such an issue uh for so many people um
what it would do is basically give them
um you know the ability to do that
law looks like we're going to move on to
page
five line
three drug checking paraphernalia should
not include drug checking equipment or
materials used in the processing
preparing packaging repackaging storing
or containing normal amounts for the
purpose of drug checking as identified
XC and I think what this is is the the
drug paraph fam your
see yeah and this this this essentially
uh is the exemption that I think we had
earlier this this basically is the part
that's telling telling them tell it
telling folks that drug checking
equipment um is basically not considered
to be drug paraphernalia under New
Hampshire
law that looks like and and the and what
it does what it also does is it
XB
okay believe that's it for uh what you
added for language into this uh
Amendment does anyone on the committee
have any questions Pros cons about the
US Representative new I mean I guess I
just say um I think that this really
responds a lot to um very well to the to
the feedback that we've gotten
um since the first iteration of it um
and includes what we've already made law
I just I think that it's um I can't see
any problems with it I guess that's what
I'll say and I think that it resolves a
lot of the problems that we've been
going back and forth about for the last
your real quick um I appreciate all of
the hours you spent on and all the work
um I I and I we too have done um a lot
of uh looking into this in other states
and in theory and everything this sounds
and looks great but in practice it has
not um is not panned out um I still see
it's
just I still don't it doesn't set right
with me all these um changes and
so that's really really
it nothing F thank you uh
representative I understand the concern
that uh that some folks have with
uh the idea that drug checking is
something that might
enable um bad behavior you know
essentially or or you know behavior that
we're not trying to
encourage I think part of what we're
really trying to do and I think the
whole thing that we're trying to do here
is to help um is to help save a few more
lives I I think we realize that given
the the nature of the fentanyl epidemic
epidemic and given the nature of drug
use we're not going to reach everybody
but um drug checking in particular has
been shown to be extremely effective you
know in colleges um parties Gatherings
things like that um not necessarily ever
going to be 100% effective but um you
know it's discouraging uh I think a
couple of weeks ago there was an article
in the Manchester Union leader that
updated you know the drug fatality
statistics and I mean despite of all the
efforts of law enforcement all the
efforts of folks like Miss McGinley and
the harm reduction community all the
efforts of folks in this
legislature um we still have people
dying at a very high rate of Fentanyl
and opioid
overdoses and I think one of the things
I just want to make sure that everybody
understands is I I am in no way with
this bill trying to get in the way of
anything that law enforcement is doing
to uh to make it harder for people who
are bringing these drugs in the market
um uh I'm you know I I think all of
those efforts are are are are fine and
we probably should be brainstorming more
ways to help help law enforcement with
things like that this is simply another
way to come at it you know one of the
things I think that we're all none of us
want is to see any more people die in
this epidemic and there are very few
things we can do in our law that can
create uh a result uh and you know this
is one of them it's been consistently
shown uh to be effective in states where
it's implemented like anything that we
do it's not 100% effective um but it's
better than what we have now and in the
middle of an epidemic I'll take better
than what we have now
anytime thank you representative re um I
think that it depends on what statistics
you look at um because um in Oregon
there has been no proven decrease in
overdose death overdose deaths with
these harm reduction measures um and
also uh um one thing that I was told is
that if you remove some of these um
penalties that um one Avenue for people
to seek help is through incarceration
their first entry into a recovery
program is through incarceration and
we're taking that away
um by these some I mean xylazine has
proven great in the um fentanyl test
strips but I think that um you know to
further this along has not fished out in
areas like Portland Oregon where they're
they had passed laws similar to this
with and they're are you know working
them back because they just are not
working so um I guess we can find
statistics to support you know what we
want a point we want to make um when we
have to look at really in real life
what's going on Portland um is not a
model City
for you know our legislation that we're
trying to propose if it was successful
and you know and and it they had hard
quality you know if they weren't in the
news every day with how terrible things
are going I might be more open to it but
it's just not work it's not the image
that is is being shown it's not as
effective as we had hoped thank you
thank you represent
man um just a couple points of
clarification because what Oregon did
was Oregon passed they legalized uh it's
different for different drugs right um
different substances but I think for
heroin for example it's one gram we're
talking about 10 milligrams which that's
one 100th one thing I I wish what what
I've learned learned is that in in um
Massachusetts for example when they
passed uh you know this this type of
legislation and they used rather than
using the word nominal amount which we
have defined as uh 10 milligrams what
they used was residual amount and I I H
I I honestly wish that we could just use
that they actually tried to clarify it
because people weren't comfortable with
having it VI a word like that that that
wasn't more clear so we're trying to
clarify it based on the cdc's definition
of what is the very little but what I
but I uh you know I I think um the the
spoon for example was very um um Visual
and being able to actually Envision what
that is but residual is is literally
like what is left in a bag after you
empty it out so if we're if we're
talking about I mean I could i' I've
read the stud read some studies about um
what happened in Oregon and Oregon has
um their overdose deaths have increased
at the same rate as other all around the
rest of the country I mean it's just
it's it's comparable yes yes it's
increased and um so so has it here so
has it in many other places so it's it's
it's not anyway um I don't I don't think
they're in any worse position but the
fact is is what they did was they
legalized up to a gram for example
that's a very different amount than what
we're trying to do here so I just really
want to to hone in and clarify that
we're not talking about
decriminalization of um of of like a
gram of anything or you know I mean it's
it's it's a very different prospect that
what we're talking about here and very
very focused on this one thing so when
we compare it to places like Oregon and
and you know I'm not going to say
anything about Oregon you know but but
the fact is is when we compare it to
laws that have
legalized 100 times as much as what this
is I think we're doing a real disservice
to actually like paying attention to to
what is in this bill and you know
looking at how effective or you know uh
what the impact of it would be because
we're just not comparing Apples to
Apples here
so thank you representative and this is
this is where I'm torn again like I said
at the last meeting that I don't want to
see people die I just really wish that
we could get to the root cause of
addiction and I know that's almost like
a a a journey that it's almost seems
impossible
uh having the law enforcement background
I see both sides so this is where I'm
kind of on the teeter totter uh the
testimony that we've heard over this has
been has been excellent
uh again we just really need to get down
to the root cause of it
and prevent people from taking this
journey that they probably never wanted
to in the first place uh if there's
nothing further does uh any member have
present I move uh ought to pass uh HB uh
470 with Amendment uh
2023-24 22 is there a
second okay and the motion before us is
ought to pass with representative Muse's
Amendment and I will take a role uh
representative
Newman what you oh I I I thought you had
to pause I apologize uh representative
Muse yes representative Newell
yes and the chair votes yes and it is
motion ought to pass with amendment by a
vote of 4 to one
yes and I hereby close criminal justice
e
welcome to the criminal justice um
subcommittee on bail bills that have
been retained we are going to be
discussing um the final version today
we're going to stop for a few minutes
and hopefully we're waiting for a couple
shortly I'm going to use tring to go
find my phone okay I'm going to email my
focus picture so I
can you going to can you email I'm doing
it
now
here today should be uh relatively short
since we last met we took a tenative
vote on a proposal and um over over the
weekend since then um I have had
conversations with uh many
stakeholders and um representative gath
and I have also had conversations and
we've decided to to fine-tune it a
little bit more and um add some new
proposals so I'm going to read these and
we're going to see if we can get a
consensus on these so that we can get
them printed up keeping in mind we have
to have this voted out next week the
deadline is the 17th and we need to get
them out by the 15th just so we can make
sure OS has the right language to go to
the floor so the current bail statute as
it is is going to have several changes
but substantially the structure isn't
changing new felony arrest for somebody
who's out on
bail already is held for a judge so if
you are out on bail and you get arrested
for a felony you are held for the judge
if it's a weekend if it's a uh excuse me
if it's a weekday if it's a weekend you
will be heard by one of the magistrates
and I'm going to get into that in a
second um so in effect no one's going to
be held for more than 24 hours with
somebody without somebody hearing their
their case deciding whether or not
they're going to go on
bail um and remember this is in response
to the Senate bill that
had um a whole list of people who just
were going to be held for four
days um with no opportunity to be heard
by
anyone uh next is um let me see anyone
who's arrested for a class A M
misdemeanor while they're out on bail if
they have a history of two or more
misdemeanor convictions convictions they
will also be in the same situation as if
someone had been arrested for a felony
does everyone get that so youve get your
felony if you get do a felony while
you're on Bale you're held and if you
have a new class A misdemeanor with a
history of two misdemeanor convections
also held again same 24-hour rule
applies either magistrate or judge
week yeah it is helpful actually CU I'm
reading off the tiny print um next we
added the um we added the felony
versions of the Senate Bill the senate
had 13 crimes that they were proposing
that could not be heard by a bill
commissioner we took that list but we're
only adopting the felony versions of it
not the misdemeanor versions of it um
there was some discussion whether or not
not we should keep possession of child
pornography on there as to whether or
not that made someone a danger or not um
we're of the opinion that um that should
be for a judge to decide not for us
that's a serious enough crime that who
knows what else you're involved in if
you have child pornography it could be
that you are involved in manufacturing
certainly you are supporting through
your um possession of that the
trade so again the Senate list of the 13
crimes we are adopting as they requested
but only the felony versions not the
misdemeanors that would be held and not
be able to see a judge I mean excuse me
a baill
commissioner um the electronic
monitoring we discussed we're still
going to keep it but we're going to
mandate it just more surgically to where
it's most appropriate and that's people
who get a domestic violence restraining
order on them that says you cannot be in
contact or within so many feet of
somebody those people are going to be
mandated to have to wear if they're
bailed a electronic monitor where they
can ensure that that person does not go
where they're not supposed to go um
which would be caused for immediate
arrest and if you are arrested for a
violation of a straining order that's
also not bailable until you see a
judge the bail fee we've already
discussed we're increasing it at $50 the
Court's going to pay it to the bail
Commissioners
monthly the court can recoup the money
from the defendants as we discussed
earlier if they're indent the Court can
make a determination of that um whether
or not to make them pay we are going to
allow the court a year to collect if
they decide the person can um my
conversations with the court has
generally they don't pursue collecting
funds from people who are Indigent
however they'll make that determination
because it's coming out of their budget
so if they uh if they want to get their
money back they've got a year to do it
next
um the education of bail Commissioners
we've already discussed that that has
not changed still the um the requirement
will stay for the times and for new bail
Commissioners and for
magistrates um we're adding that victims
can be heard in any bail hearing victims
will have the right now to go to a bail
hearing and argue why the person should
not have bail that would be the hearing
in front of the judge not with a bail
commissioner or magistrate in the middle
of the night but at the original bail
hearing when they get to the judge if
someone is released on bail
and there's a victim it's a crime
against a person the police have to
notify the um victim within um to give
them one hour before the person's
released so right now person just gets
released and if they get notified they
get notified before the person can be
released they have to notify the victim
one hour prior to that if the victim
leaves their contact information so that
they can get them um let me see and the
police have have to document the fact in
the time where they went to notify the
person the police are allowed to notify
them earlier if someone's picked up and
it appears they're going to make bail
the police can go say it looks like he's
going to make bail here's your
notification but in no case can it be
less than an
hour um and finally U bail Commissioners
or magistrates and judges must provide
the accused with information on local
Services related to homelessness hunger
mental health and substance abuse issues
when they're picked up bail
Commissioners already have to hand them
a stack of paperwork that's provided by
the court this is just going to be one
more piece of paper the court has to
print for whatever bail commission the
locality the bail commissioner serves so
they can hand out this information to
the person um when they are
bailed and that is the substance of the
changes discussion what so if the go
ahead I Mr chairman if I may just
clarify the the notification of a victim
is that where the police or you know
somebody has to attempt to make contact
with that victim or is it actually
making the contact like let's say the
person just you know didn't answer their
phone or they're just kind of hiding for
a little bit and don't want to answer
their phone what what exactly how that
looked the way we're contemplating
writing it is that the police have to
make an effort to contact the victim at
the name and address that they leave if
they are not able to leave them they
have to leave a message or a
notification at the address saying that
here's your notification this person is
released we're not going to hold people
while the they're chasing down the
victims cuz sometimes steer point they
may not even they may not care beond the
arrest further discussion representative
Harry gther you might want to add that
because right now we just have iners or
telephone okay when we put the when we
put the language for the actual it'll
say may notify this way and that way and
we'll put that in
there
um yeah it will be documented uh
representative
Muse yes um first of all thank you for
the uh for the work on this this is
we've been a long been a long tough road
getting uh getting to a point where we
actually have some things that we've
we've agreed on there uh there were some
things that um you did not mention that
I just wanted to make sure what the
status of those were to um one of them I
know is one is something that's pretty
near and dear to your heart which is the
the syst that would actually connect uh
law enforcement to bail bail status
information uh that the court system has
my my understanding that's part of this
as well that is correct I I didn't bring
that up because it wasn't a change I
thought we discussed it last week but a
good point um the the bill portion that
pertains to technology we will be
providing
$750,000 to the Department of Public
Safety and $950,000 to the court to make
the law enforcement and the court system
talk to each other in spots so that bail
will be updated as quick to as real time
is possible and law enforcement and
through law enforcement bail
Commissioners or magistrates will know
if someone's on bail and what their
record is at the time they make the bail
so that will be included in the in the
bill there are a couple of other things
oh go on by all means just just just to
make sure we have them another one is
the reinsertion of the original bail
reform uh provision uh that doesn't
allow people accused of criminal
offenses to be held simply because they
can't make a cash bail it's basically
yes you can be held if you're a Flight
Risk if you keep getting arrested or
you've been shown by clear and
convincing evidence to be a person of
high risk when it comes to committing
another violent crime but no um if it's
just you can't make bail because you
can't afford it that is correct we are
the the current statute um provides for
that no one shall be held and we're not
changing that um I believe even the
first uh paragraph may even reiterate
that no one shall be held just because
of the fact that they don't have money
to to make a bail or no bail shall be
set for the sole purpose of keeping
someone because the court knows they
don't have money so um we're definitely
staying away from you're either
dangerous and you're held or you're not
you're a Flight Risk in you're held or
you're not um if you're released there
can be conditions but we're not
contemplating cash as part of that and
the the the final one was the
establishment of a of a Governor's
commission uh to actually work out how
to make uh pre-trial interventions more
consistent across the counties uh
potentially involving funding and things
of that nature which we found in our
discussions to be pretty inconsistent
pretty irregular um and very much
necessary if we're actually going to
move the needle you know in terms of of
uh trying to address the problem of
homeless people people with mental
health and substance abuse issues
getting arrested over and over and over
again um yeah thank you um in our in our
studies we've determined that such a
commission already exists um it's called
the inter Branch commission that has all
the same people that we want it was the
people that work well not the exact
people but the same offices that worked
on the original 2018 bill it has the
Judiciary it has the um attorney general
it's got the um County attorney it's got
everybody who could possibly be involved
what we're going to do is retask that
committee rather commission rather than
create a new Commission because they
still exist I was approached by the
speaker's office whether or not that
should be repealed because they're going
through looking at all these zombie
commissions that are out there and I
told them no this one not we're actually
going to use it so um what you discussed
is um among the things several things
we're going to task them with one of
them being being to look at a potential
Statewide pre-trial Services um and
methods to maybe make that happen such
as create a fund that counties if they
create a system can apply to for um
potential reimbursement if they meet a
minimum criteria things of that nature
um we were also going to have them look
at a total top- down review of the
criminal justice system with regard to
the way the agencies and counties
interact during all the hearings we've
had the hundreds of ours testimony we
saw large disconnects um between the
branches and between agencies within the
same Branch um and it came to our
attention that the whole thing needs to
be looked at from the top down and I
think that's a perfect job for that that
group what else were we gonna
representative Ro if you
recall oh um thank you Mr chairman um I
I did speak with a few people whenever I
was here early today uh one of the
things that you and I I discussed was
about making sure that there's actually
a victim's Advocate division in all of
the courts and currently there most
definitely is something for sexual
assaults and my understanding is that
the public defender's office I'm sorry
that the um attor oh my gosh the county
attorney's office does have uh victim
Advocates but it's it's really unclear
as
to what extent they are able to advocate
for for some of these victims so in
other words if somebody happens to be
you know mugged on the street you know
what actually are the parameters of this
victim's Advocate to to help and a lot
of times the victim's Advocate is really
just a a communication person between
the victim and the actual attorney so we
want to actually make sure that the that
the services are are made available to
the victim as you know we hear so often
about services that are actually made up
to the person that is arrested so we're
going to work on that yeah I um I'd
actually we're going to ask them to to
look into the potential to create a
specific office within the Judiciary or
somewhere either in there or within the
County attorneys um I prefer actually
the court um an office of victim witness
Advocate often Witnesses are left
hanging in the wind um and they're often
threatened and they also risk a lot of
things or need services so um it's
inconsistent right now I believe across
all the counties in the state
as far as the availability of someone
who knows how to help or get them with
the protection they need or whatnot um
so we're going to ask them also to look
into that the creation of a victim
witness Advocate was there anything else
we had a whole laundry list of things we
wanted to ask them to do and that bill
will be brought to us next week on uh
Tuesday when we exec and it will I'll
send it out this weekend for everyone to
see the final version um of things we're
going to ask them to look into as part
Charter and just one one thing I want to
say is this is something that we've done
on some of the environmental commissions
as well is uh you know periodically we
do uh update when we actually renew some
of the commissions we we update their
Charters so this is not something that's
irregular I I think it just sort of
points out the the need to you know to
to Bas basically the fact that a legis
work is never done uh we need to keep
looking at this stuff and keep finding
ways to improve things keep finding new
ways to get um additional input and make
sure we're listening to the right people
um so sounds like that's what we're
doing yeah absolutely I think that um we
need to use the tools at our disposal
and having this group that's made up of
all the subject matters experts come
back to us with recommendations for
legislation versus us in our own Silo
trying to come up with something that'll
fix it is much more efficient and um
should have more weight also I wanted to
add one more thing that I had neglected
to mention as part of it um as part of
the bill with regard to Bales um
currently the um the district attorney
not district attorney the County
attorneys can appeal appeal a bail
decision but they have to move for a
revocation of bail and what we heard was
it often takes sometimes weeks so in
very limited cases where it's for
dangerousness only the county attorney
will be able to appeal a circuit court
judge on release on dangerousness issues
and that person will be held up to 48
hours for a superior court hearing only
on that issue um so it does give them a
a fail safe if they extremely believe
that a judge has made an error and it's
dangerous to the society they can excuse
no or judge um the circuit court judge
makes it an error in the opinion of the
of the uh County attorney on a very
limited issue of dangerousness they can
appeal and the person will be held for a
maximum of 48 hours for the Superior
Court to hold a hearing on the appeal um
again it's narrow but it is it is
something and it gives them at least the
opportunity to make one more argument
about dangerousness and I think that was
everything we discussed um
representative gather do you think can
you recall anything else I might have
missed no okay okay so any further
discussion questions concerns before we
send to the presses not the press the
presses go ahead representative um thank
you Mr chair are we still looking to do
anything around text notifications of
Court
hearings we uh I've spoken to the court
and they are looking into that as part
of the um the technology upgrade that
we're proposing for them I I'm loed to
mandate that they do that or how they do
that because um it's complex and the it
would be hard for us to tell them how to
do it I don't want to get down into the
weeds like that um it's just going to be
part of the technology and they're very
eager to do it um I had a conversation
with the Chief Justice and he thought it
was a great idea and he's seen it done
in the pilot program before and thinks
it's it's worthy of
pursuit
okay everyone at this point raise your
hand if you're in favor of everything I
discussed so that I can send it to the
OS
okay it looks like unanimous very good
please watch your email over the weekend
when I get it back more or less I'll
send out a hard copy to everybody on
what we will be
voting um and we will be meeting again
on Tuesday I don't know Tuesday Yeah
Tuesday Tuesday we're going to be
meeting actually all of us we're meeting
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Tuesday this
subcommittee will meet to finalize our
recommendation on the bail Wednesday we
meet as a whole committee to vote on
Executive session on all the retained
bills and then Thursday we have a public
hearing for a non-gain amendment to one
of the bail bills at the request of one
of the County attorneys who testified
before us about a technical change that
is causing them trouble with the courts
because they said we were too vague when
we changed it before so um he will come
and explain that to us in person so
that's I believe it was attorney Enders
um if you recall representative wheeler
just to make sure there's no committee
maybe no no nothing tomorrow enjoy your
uh Veterans Day weekend and with that um
adjourned